foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
[Music]
it's sentencing day
[Music]
keep Banning it sentence for four months
I need to go back and look at the tape I
believe that's what I said he would get
like four months three or four months
that's when I figured he would get it's
three or four months I think the maximum
he could have got was like 12. and this
was a misdemeanor
and welcome to the Tony Michaels podcast
I am your great host the Tony Michaels
again see been in was sentenced this
morning to four months in prison now it
is a federal court it is a misdemeanor
so what the
um what the judge has done here is
allowed Steve Bannon to go on release
while he's seeking his appeal as long as
it's timely meaning as if he [ __ ]
around he'll find out even harder
um so he's going to have to actually do
the appeals process he can't just use it
to stall he will stall a bit
and this is a misdemeanor charge it's
not a felony so that is the one of the
reasons why he was he was out on
pre-trial uh he was out during his trial
and the reason why the judges let him
lose today now Steve Bannon was smart
what he would do is go ahead and do his
sentence now and then get it over with
um to be the 2022 martyr but he's too
much of a [ __ ]
he's scared he's a scared little [ __ ]
[ __ ] is what he is
and you know that by when he comes out
of the courtroom and he acts all tough
but in the courtroom
he said nothing the judge gave him an
opportunity to say something and he said
nothing
and that just speaks volumes about Steve
Bannon himself
that everything you hear out of his
mouth is all [ __ ] and all Bluster
that when they when when it gets heated
in the moment
he can't even defend himself or fire
rain we're gonna rain tear down on you
scorched Earth or whatever the [ __ ] he
says
because there's one thing Steve Bannon
knew in this hearing
is that he could not piss this judge off
because he was going to ask this judge
to stay out on appeal
and if he pissed the [ __ ] judge off
if he Steve Bannon bits this judge off
then it was possible that just say no
you're gonna have to self-surrender
in 30 days or 60 days 90 days whatever
the self-surrender period would be for
Steve Bannon because that's generally
what happens in this in in a case like
this where you're sentenced to four
months in a federal prison for this type
of charge as you would self-surrender to
whatever facility the Bureau of Prisons
picks for you
but if Steve Bannon was smart he would
go ahead and start his sen he's going to
serve this for months and that's the
thing about a federal sentence too he's
going to do every [ __ ] day
every day of it
there's old parole or early time or
anything like that it is four months he
will do four [ __ ] months to the day
and he's not going to win on an appeal
and the reason why he won't win on an
appeal is because it was a slam dunk
case
it was cut and dry contempt of congress
criminal contempt of congress
the jury decided that easily
what he's hoping for this is what Steve
Bannon is hoping for Steve Bannon is
hoping he can stall this
until somehow Donald Trump gets crowned
King of the United States and pardons
him again
which Stephen is going to need probably
more than just a pardon for contempt of
congress to be quite honest
but as long as you engage in participate
in your democracy and don't let these
[ __ ] fascist
get control of this our democracy and
destroy it Steve Madden will serve serve
months four months and every [ __ ] day
of them every last [ __ ] day
so I know some of you feel defeated
because Steve Bannon isn't actually in a
pair of handcuffs in the cell yet but be
rest assured the feds don't [ __ ] around
when it comes to prison sentences
or [ __ ] around trying to stall for an
appeal
it doesn't normally work that way now
Steve Bannon thinks he's going to take
this as a supreme court and that's
probably his ultimate plan but they're
not no one's there aren't High courts
that are going to hear an appeal on
[ __ ] a misdemeanor contempt criminal
contempt of congress on a four-month
sentence
there was a governor
there was a governor of Virginia his
name actually escapes me at this moment
I had it a little bit ago
just a bit of a brain fart I guess she
called a brain Bannon
um he was sentenced for taking gifts you
remember this is a big trial he was the
governor and he was going to be he was
going to run for president and all this
[ __ ] and forget his name come on Chad
help me out here I know the chat I don't
know this
you know what the hell is his name
anyways the point is this I'm literally
forgetting his name at this point
there's so many [ __ ] scumbags on and
on in the Republican Party
you just you [ __ ] forget
you forget these [ __ ] idiots anyways
he was sentenced to prison and he was
held out on his appeal
and he appealed and this Supreme Court
overturned
that decision because the law had
changed and you know it's not Junkin I
wish it was Junkin but it's not youngin
Glenn youngin is the current governor
this was a former Republican governor of
Virginia
um again his name will come to me soon
I'm sure but it's just there's so many
[ __ ] scumbags everyone's saying
junkan uh Peggy he's like Junkin please
please is he going to prison
on YouTube yeah youngin yeah no it
wasn't it wasn't
it wasn't uh youngin no
um maybe one of these days
um he'll he'll get there some are saying
Edwards Edwards John Edwards uh was not
he was a Democrat he was the vice
presidential uh nominee with John Kerry
and John John Edwards went to trial for
some of the same stuff that's it
it was it was McDonald that's it
McDonald
not McConnell McDonald
um that's that's the name he he got a
watch
um there was donors taking him on big
vacations Bob is his first name Penelope
has here Bob McDonald
just go look at that case
um that case now there was felony
charges there but the judge let McDonald
out while he was appealing now he won
his appeal ultimately at the Supreme
Court right but you're talking about
felony [ __ ] bribery charges and [ __ ]
okay where there was a conviction on on
heavy felonies right
this is a misdemeanor charge okay and
really honestly in most cases of a
misdemeanor charge where it's not
violent a federal judge is less likely
to give
um a heavy sentence and really this
four-month sentence is is kind of a
heavy sentence I mean it's
you know it's a it's a a third of what
the judge can actually give them to a
maximum which is 12 months
so now if if Steve Bannon would have uh
been convicted in his other case and not
pardoned and that would have been taken
in consideration here that he would have
probably got the full 12 months but they
can't take that into consideration
because he actually has to Pardon from
Trump from his other charges that he was
indicted on so it can't be taken in
consideration right because he admitted
he did the whole build the wall scheme
and he defrauded people out of their
money he admitted to it when he took the
pardon that's what a pardon is
but because of that they couldn't use
that in the sentencing here they can't
consider that
so you know that's why he got four
months now I I I assumed it would be
anywhere between four and six months the
prosecution asked for six months they
got most of what they were asking for
which is normally the case
sometimes they get more sometimes they
get exactly but most time they get close
to what they want
so you know it's it's not
it's it's that surprising that he got
four months but again rest assured
unless barring something crazy that our
democracy Falls
Steve Bannon will serve four months in a
jail cell somewhere
or in a prison one or the other either
in a county holding cell that's
contracted or a private prison that's
contract out and Steve Bannon is about
to find out
what the private prison system feels
like and what the federal prison system
feels like now he'll go to a camp which
is you know they call it Camp fed now
there's very
um High Security federal prisons like
the super max out in Colorado but
there's also camps and that's that's
where he'll go for four months and
that's why I say if Steve Bannon was
smarty go ahead and start serving his
time just you just get it over with
right especially right now when he could
be I mean maybe he could write a a book
in prison I don't know maybe Steve
Bannon could buy the book you know a
good title for a book that Steve Bannon
could write in prison to be a martyr
for all these America First Nazis my
struggle would probably be a good name
and a good title for a book for Steve
Bannon to write while he's doing his
four-month sentence
so why why why why why Steve Bannon
isn't doing his sentence and Dave Dave
here Dave's a
um uh a trump copy machine here on the
Facebook Dave Paddock here Dave thinks
it's funny four months dude it's four
months on a misdemeanor charge you dummy
he got four months on a misdemeanor
charge
that's just contempt of congress That's
not including all the other fraud that
he's done
and what he'll be sentenced to in in the
state elector scheme because dude is
wrapped in the state elector scheme
which is obstruction of official
proceeding and also fraud
the other thing that it is is it's uh I
don't know seditious conspiracy
so he got four months on his little
misdemeanor for not going to Congress
and speaking under oath to Congress
and not complying with the subpoena
the one the other thing too that you
have to remember Dave is [ __ ]
ever ends up in a federal court being
sentenced Again by another judge you
damn well better bet they're going to
use this sentence
as as a pre-trial condition of his
sentencing and they're going to measure
it out
so yeah
good luck with that Dave good luck
good luck with it
with your little four months but he will
serve every single day that four months
every last one of them
so Steve Bannon gets four months in
prison this morning
and again again I'm not sure why he
wouldn't just take the the martyrdom
sample other than he's a [ __ ]
I mean four months and lock up come on
man four months
what are you scared of Bannon I mean
Jesus Christ
you already looked you already look like
you just walked out of a [ __ ] jail
cell for crying out loud
dude doesn't look like he's had a decent
bar of soap in 30 years
come on
buddy won't
because he's scared just like he was
scared when he defrauded Trump
supporters for money for the wall and
then Trump [ __ ] pardoned him because
he stole his supporters money
you [ __ ] know that right
Steve Bannon stole
stole
Donald Trump supporters money
by lying to them about a wall that
Donald Trump thought he wanted to build
and it was a big [ __ ] fraud scheme
stole their [ __ ] money just like
Donald Trump stealing their money now
stole their [ __ ] money
and then Donald Trump pardoned Steve
Bannon for stealing his supporters
[ __ ] money
best part about the whole [ __ ] thing
is [ __ ] was arrested on those
charges that he was indicted for for
fraud for the build the wall scheme
where he he stole
and defrauded Trump supporters money
from them
he was arrested on a Chinese dude's boat
a Chinese Nationals boat the chi-coms
as Stewart Rhodes this week was saying
it into
in their signal chats
him and Kelly surreal and The Oath
Keepers they were talking about the
chi-coms
like somehow China is going to take over
the United States and Donald Trump isn't
cat Crown King or some weird ass [ __ ]
q and on conspiracy theory [ __ ] all the
while their best buddy Steve Bannon
is on a chi-com's boat
yucking it up
eating steaks drinking drinking God
knows how expensive a booze
on the backs of Donald Trump supporter
that he stole from
you people really are [ __ ] dumb
this is laughable absolutely laughable
that Trump supporters still support him
honestly folks it is a good sign of who
we know is dumb as [ __ ] dumber than dog
[ __ ] at this point
and no better than Dave here cheering on
Steve Bannon that he got sentenced to
four months in a federal prison which
he'll serve every day for
because he was held in contempt to
Congress because if he actually went in
on that subpoena they would [ __ ] they
would refer felonies which they're
already gonna [ __ ] refer because they
they got the evidence
but he couldn't self-incriminate
and Steve Bannon knew he didn't want to
be on tape pleading the fifth because
he'd look guilty like Flynn and Stone
you people really are [ __ ] boneheads
don't you see where this is headed
don't you see can't you [ __ ] figure
it out and unwind your q and on Web of
Lies
that you've created for yourself this
Grand Story
about how Donald Trump's the greatest
president of all time and he's the best
at owning the libtards of whatever the
[ __ ] it is that you believe
you were about to lose every [ __ ] one
of those of those storylines
and this four-month sentence is just the
beginning
and he's such a [ __ ] nincompoop Nazi
he's such a little [ __ ] that he
couldn't go serve his time like his hero
Hitler did
he should have just requested that he
started his sentence immediately now the
judge could deny that request
but he could say I want to start serving
immediately
and judge because they yeah sure go
ahead and take him in custody and his
sentence would his because he's gonna
get a day he's already got a day worth
of credit
because he was he was arrested and
arraigned you remember that you remember
the great perp block that they did with
him he gets a full day's credit for that
Steve Bannon gets a full day's credit
for that for that per block
he'll get a full day
but he should have just said take me
into Cassidy and it would have started
now
by the time the election's over and by
the time we get to January and Trump is
getting indicted and all the Trump
candidates who lose are claiming the
election was stolen and to stop the
steal and we must create another
Insurrection to overthrow the government
overthrow our democracy because it's not
fair because we lost and we suck and it
sucks to suck
he could be coming out of prison and be
the hero but he doesn't even see that
foreign
they're so [ __ ] they're so [ __ ]
blinded by their treason looking through
their treason glasses
because the whole thing's a grift
the entire [ __ ] thing
listen Steve Bannon Donald Trump Roger
Stone Mike Flynn and the rest of them
the only reason why they're doing a lot
of what they're doing Marjorie Taylor
green and the like is because they're
scared to sit in a jail cell
that's why they're scared to sit in a
jail cell
they're terrified of it
if they if Steve Bannon was not
terrified to sit in a jail cell he would
have surrendered himself today
and started ticking off the four months
he's already got one day credit
he might as well get four months while
you have his appeal
because he's not gonna win the appeal
it's just gonna delay the inevitable of
the four months that's it
and and he can't get around the four
months the judge has already ordered it
it is four months
that's what the judge ordered
so the only way he'll get out of the
four months is if he wins his appeal
which is completely delusional the same
way it was delusional that he thought he
was going to have a great defense in
court for his criminal contempt of
congress
which he did not
so yeah I know it feels disappointing
this morning
I know it feels disappointing this
morning that he's not toted off to jail
yet but trust me when I say this Steve
Bannon not not handing himself over
today is even worse for Steve Bannon
it's even worse for Steve Bannon
worth it
trust me when I tell you this
because when Steve Bannon loses his
appeal
oh buddy are you gonna see him and all
these [ __ ] like Dave here on Facebook
melt into puddles of ice cream
because this is this is the narrative is
that they're going to win the appeal I
mean it's rock solid just like his case
was Rock Solid right
the [ __ ] out of here this is all
nonsense that his case was Rock Solid
listen
a subpoena from Congress is a lawful
subpoena
and if you try to not
and you obstruct that subpoena you can
be held in contempt
and Congress can not only hold you in
contempt they can send a criminal
referral to the Department of Justice
and the Department of Justice can then
decide if they're going to use a grand
jury to indict you and if they indict
you they'll take you to [ __ ] Court in
trial and if you decide to go to trial
and you lose your case and the jury
decides that you're guilty of the charge
then the judge can sentence you these
are all facts this is all real world
stuff that happens this isn't some kind
of [ __ ] movie you dumb [ __ ]
this isn't CSI this isn't [ __ ]
Criminal Minds this is real life
and I know you [ __ ] live in fantasy I
know you moglodytes out there like Dave
here in the chat living a [ __ ]
fantasy world
but the courts and Bop don't they don't
they don't give a [ __ ] what you idiots
believe
of the lies
and and he keeps right if if there is no
if Steve Bannon will serve for months
your if is if he wins appeal dummy
which he will not win appeal
just like he had no Rock Solid case here
because not only not only does Steve
Bannon now being charged with it have an
uphill battle with appeal he has to
convince federal judges not juries dummy
and federal judges know what contempt is
who do you think most of the time
actually [ __ ] holds people in
contempt
that's why this judge was No Nonsense
when they were trying to make their
stupid [ __ ] argument
I'll see here and now he's deflecting
again
see
Red Wave 18 days away okay Dave
talk about in 18 days come back I doubt
you will
I doubt you will redwave my [ __ ] ass
see that's what they're counting on do
you see do you see that's Dave's
narrative Dave's the Dave just like fake
game is the Trump copy machine
just just like the Trump copy machine
oh just wait just just wait two weeks
man two more oh man Healthcare two weeks
away
infrastructure two weeks away Hillary
Clinton's arrest two weeks away lock her
up just wait just wait Steve Bannon was
sentenced to four months in prison today
you dumb [ __ ]
Hillary Clinton wasn't sentenced to
prison Barack Obama was not sentenced to
prison
you you people are dumb [ __ ]
and really frankly honestly this is what
we need in this country is these people
to be absolutely absolutely humiliated
because that's what's going to happen
the humiliation is going to be very
heavy and pile on top of these dummies
it really is
because no one looking at the case of
Steve Bannon objectively claiming to be
for Law and Order
would think that oh well he was
mistreated in the court system give me a
[ __ ] break
it was easy it was an easy case
even Steve bannon's attorney said in
open court we don't even have a defense
what defense are you leaving us because
they didn't have one
Congress had referred the criminal
contempt to the doj the doj had a grand
jury indict him
and it's a simple charge
Steve Bennett was admitting it on his
show that he was doing it
foreign
he wasn't even denying that he did this
thing
and he tried to bring Donald Trump into
it and apparently the the Donald Trump's
attorney brought him into it today too
about executive privilege and all this
[ __ ] and apparently there was a little
scuffle between Donald Trump's attorneys
who were there in the courtroom and
Steve bannon's attorney and apparently
Steve bannon's attorney does not like
Donald Trump because he's [ __ ] stolen
money from him he owes you money which
is not surprising that Donald Trump owns
owes Steve Banning another attorney
especially Steve bannon's attorney money
or some [ __ ]
I don't know what the actual beef there
is in the courtroom but they were live
tweeting that there was some beef
between Steve bannon's attorney and
Donald Trump's attorney
so again I know I know Twitter and and
the left and Democrats are going to feel
defeated this morning but B be very
confident
that Steve Bannon is going to serve
every [ __ ] day of this four
months for this charge
for this charge and that is where the
beauty of the story will get better
that is where the beauty of the story is
going to come and it's going to be it's
gonna Blossom it's gonna bloom and
you're really gonna see the [ __ ] around
and find out Saga with Steve Bannon
and Steve Bannon is going to find out
because it looks more and more like the
evidence that we've seen
from the January 6 select committee that
he was part of this state elector scheme
and because Steve Bannon it doesn't
appear that he has went before the grand
jury on the state elector scheme he's a
target of it because that's generally
what happens too with grand juries
grand juries normally don't interview
the target
they interview the assets and the
witnesses to the Target
so because Donald Trump John Eastman
Steve Bannon Mike Flynn
haven't been Rudy Giuliani haven't been
in that grand jury
that's only a sign that they're a Target
that's why Lindsey Graham going before a
grand jury in Georgia is not a that's
not a a bad thing for Lindsay he just
doesn't want to self-incriminate
he doesn't want to accidentally say
something or give a piece of evidence
away look listen he's a lawyer he was a
Jag lawyer that's actually the one thing
that Lindsey Graham did in his life
I mean he hasn't done anything else
since
he was a Jag lawyer
so he knows he knows the risk
and the risk is if you say anything
anything that ties back to another piece
of evidence that that any prosecutor may
have you may be [ __ ] because you've
done said it under oath
that's that's what these Trump idiots
don't understand
and that's what Trump doesn't understand
they don't get it they don't get it
Lindsey Graham knows
I mean as much as I want to make fun of
Lady G he's not stupid
and really he's smart for trying to
challenge to go before the grand jury
because he knows he's not a Target
Lindsey Graham Listen to Me Lindsey
Graham is not a Target
they want his evidence for the targets
that's why they want to interview him in
the grand jury
that's why
I'm no [ __ ] lawyer
but you don't need you don't need to be
a lawyer to know that all the [ __ ] you
see on TV is all [ __ ]
like the crime shows CSI Law and Order
that's all nonsense that's all the
packed end of give you a good hour show
that's all it is is to keep you
entertained frankly the problem is we
have such [ __ ] brainless idiots in
this country that don't know that that
shit's not real
because reality TV is seeped into our
[ __ ] brains in this country that we
don't know that reality TV and
television and movies is not real it's
not [ __ ] real like The Apprentice was
not real it was all fake all of it
including that he's a great businessman
that [ __ ] was fake
that shit's fake
it was all set up it was just TV
and that's why you got to stop listening
to look if you're gonna watch TV if
you're going to watch movies It's
Entertainment folks It's Entertainment
it's not real a good one is House
Hunters you guys seen House Hunters I
haven't watched it in a long time
a lot of people don't know that shit's
fake
I how are you not aware of this reality
TV is not real
but Steve Bannon getting four months in
prison is absolutely [ __ ] real and
it's reality and boy is it really gonna
slap him in the face when he has to
serve every single day of the four month
sentence and we're excited about it here
at the Tony Michaels podcast just like
we're excited about your excitement
about voting and standing in line it's
getting cold outside folks it's getting
cold it's getting cold outside don't
forget to stay warm while you're waiting
in line there might be some long lines
here here next month on on Election Day
get your the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people's not Liberty
hoodie zip up hoodie and sweatshirt at
store not the Tony michaels.com
store.thedonymichaels.com
show your support we appreciate your
gangs of support we actually run off of
it if you want to give us a tip we
appreciate that we got a lot of people
give us daily tips some people sign up
to give us monthly so that you can set
it and forget it you don't have to you
don't have to worry about it
we appreciate all your support you're
the best audience in the world we even
love our hate Watchers here
so uh if you want to keep continuing
hate watching why don't you go over and
give us a tip Tony Michaels dot live
Tony Michaels dot live tip and give us a
tip over there
we got bonehead of the week bone hand
out of the week and guess what Gabe
Sanchez is back with us today that's
right that's right
he is no longer on the film set of the
George Soros Medical Group he was
shooting a lot of propaganda videos for
the George Soros Medical Group I'm not
sure exactly what it was
but uh he's going to be joining us for
bonehead a week so everyone stick around
we'll do a little bit of shitless
Roundup when we come back and then we'll
go to Bone end of the week an hour two
thanks for joining us we'll be right
back right after these messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
great
it's Friday
of the week
second hour will be Johnny Michael but
as it is every single Friday
Gabe Sanchez is back joining us today I
promise I promise he'll be here he's
doing some vinyl touches do you guys
like the new TV screen everyone has been
saying oh the the newscast behind you is
is distracting so I just decided to put
the logo up there does that look better
maybe we'll cycle it through some slides
too I don't know
show you guys some new merch up there or
something maybe we'll put some funny
memes up there I don't know the logo you
know that's a normal thing I guess what
do you guys think there were some people
that were kept messaging me hey the TV
screen's distracting I wasn't
distracting me I wasn't looking at it it
was behind me
oh I listened to all the criticism here
on the Tony Michaels podcast I promise I
I try to read as many comments as I can
I try to read all your guys's uh
criticism I take it I pick take it very
seriously I have a very thick skin trust
me so there's nothing you can say that
will offend me trust me I mean I might
come after you a little bit you know I
might give you a little bit of pushback
but I still love you
I love you
and really honestly and someone asked
about uh my replies the other day and I
said look sometimes I get so many I just
I can't reply to all of them but I try
to I really do I try to read your guys's
comments I try to see what you're saying
it um it's super important to me because
I think you guys are a great audience
you got one of the most engaged
audiences that that exist
really honestly I mean we we have we we
just went over 11 000 subscribers on our
YouTube channel uh the other day
and we get we we get almost 10 of that
audience comes and engages almost live
every single day now rather it's on
Facebook or YouTube or Twitter or twitch
we get a huge part of that audience
coming and engaging right here live
every single day and I know that's
important to you guys
I know it's important to come and talk
to folks in the chat while I'm yelling
and screaming into a microphone
so do me a favor do me a favor if you
aren't subscribed to the YouTube channel
already hit the Subscribe button it's
really easy
and share this share this with a friend
with a family member a colleague
I'm I'm not scared yet share it with
your Trump trump loving Trump humping
your family members it's all right I'm
not scared of them come on come in the
chat come you know say ignorant stuff
type out ignorant stuff you just trust
me the moderators because we have some
great moderators MJ Margie and Robin on
YouTube they will they will absolutely
at you if you say some outlandish [ __ ]
and you know what I'm talking about
but but
so be nice you can be you can be
ignorant but just be nice about it so we
appreciate even the hate Watchers here
and we appreciate the moderators now
keeping those hate Watchers and check if
they need to be so everyone gives some
love to MJ Margie and Robin
um they do a great job in the YouTube
chat a lot of times they have to trade
off sometimes one of them can't watch
live and they're so good about making
sure who who's here and who's not and
they help each other they're helping you
through the chat
um they're great and I I love them from
the bottom of my heart we have the best
moderators here on YouTube I I truly I
truly believe that they know that
because we have a little chat that
they're in that we talk to them every
day and they talk to us so we try to
keep them up to speed and they know
what's coming
now we know what's coming because a lot
of times I can't get through all the
comments so they'll Point some stuff out
to me like hey this this comment keeps
being said
um so we we really do try to I try to
read everything that you guys type out
whether it's on YouTube even you trolls
out there I try to make sure I read
everything that I possibly can I can't
get to all of it
um but I try to read it if I'm not
replying to you it's either you're a
troll and I don't give trolls food or or
I just I just don't have time to reply
to every single comment I try to do the
likes and stuff like that
um and emojis but uh I I really I really
do appreciate you guys as an audience
it's growing fast it's growing rapidly
we're getting more and more views
um not just here on YouTube but Facebook
is growing and right now if you're on
Facebook because we we air from the
might just touch Facebook page and my
page so go follow us at the Tony
Michaels on my Facebook page because boy
the Facebook thing is really growing and
I think it's the hate Watchers over
there we it seems like we got more
Hangout launchers over on Facebook than
any other place and I don't know if
that's because all the trumpers live
over on Facebook or not I have no idea
I'm not really sure exactly why there's
so many Watchers it might be because we
air for the Midas touch Facebook page
that's where all those hate Watchers are
coming in at
you know they're keeping tabs on
anything they do right because Oh that's
oh any pro-democracy speech is the enemy
of fascism so we're gonna go attack it
we're the Trump copy machine we had our
Tech we got a Tech Pro democracy groups
out there people who are pro-democracy
who believe in equality and Equity
that's gross we don't want equality
inequity we want bigotry
speaking of bigots I have a video I want
to show you Matt Walsh I [ __ ] went
off on him yesterday and I'm gonna do it
again today so let's get to the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends we're running
out of time
let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
y tweets and the trendy trends of the
day now boy do I have some video to show
you Gabe Sanchez is going to be joining
us any minute now
he's probably listening right now he's
he's finishing up some of the bonehead
assets I think you know all the great
artwork that comes in
for bonehead Gabe does that in the
morning on Friday mornings he puts that
together as I'm talking as we're going
he's throwing that together as we speak
making it all look good so we have all
those Graphics forever bonehead of the
week so don't go anywhere because we're
gonna do the [ __ ] list Roundup and then
the second hour as we do every single
Friday
every single Friday we are going to do
bonehead of the week here and boy do we
have
some boneheads I'm sure Steve Bannon
will work his way into
um one of these special mentions for
today but let's go to some to some video
here on the timeline in the Tweety
tweets and trendy Trends here we go here
it is here's the
scumbag Nazi Matt Walsh and this was my
response I said this comeback Nazi is
fantasizing about rounding up our lgbtq
plus brothers and sisters willing to use
federal law enforcement when they regain
power look
you should listen when they tell you who
they are
okay now
right now they're yelling and screaming
at the top of their lungs because
they're orange Mussolini Jesus is about
to [ __ ] around and find out about
federal law enforcement and the FBI they
believe that federal law enforcement is
egregious it should be disbanded
defund the FBI get rid of federal law
enforcement get rid of IRS agents like
any federal agent out there they want
rid of because it is a risk that Trump
is going to go to jail
but as soon as they regain power folks
as soon as they regain power oh they
love they love federal troops they love
Stormtroopers so much so that they'll
actually go lock people up just for who
they are just for who they are
and what their what their world view is
sounds familiar doesn't it
listen they're not hiding it
fascist like Matt Walsh are not hiding
this [ __ ] anymore they used to thin bail
this stuff they used to you know kind of
dance around the point they're not
they're telling you when we regain power
we are going to come round you up even
if we have to use federal law
enforcement to do it that's why they're
bitching about the FBI right now because
they're all [ __ ] criminals and the
FBI is smoking them out like crazy
because of the Insurrection because they
tried to overthrow our government and
committed crimes doing it
so they're pissed off that the federal
government is coming after them for
committing crimes but what they want to
do is they want to make it criminal to
be who you are
that's what they want to do now this is
some really sick [ __ ] that he says in
this video
and it I thought about it this morning
that I almost didn't want to retweet
this or do this but listen sunlight is
the best disinfectant and I'm telling
you folks
Matt Walsh is laying out the absolute
fascist wet dream here
because if he if he can get what he
wants what he says in this video they
can Round Up anyone for thinking
anything
and holding any beliefs and that's
really their goal here
is to normalize
normalize criminalizing people's beliefs
folks these are not people of freedom
and liberty
this guy uses uses freedom of speech and
our constitution
and our in our great March for equality
and equity in this country which is
Liberty
as his tool to convince [ __ ] boxes out
there that are easily diluted into
believing that the problems that the
nation has is the others
the people who think differently
the people who have a different religion
or have no religion
or or uh what what kind of this guy is
completely obsessed with genitalia and
what is even further disturbing about
Matt Walsh is that he is absolutely 100
percent
focused laser focused on children's
genitalia
this guy is a [ __ ] sicko
he's a fascist nazi sicko
and this video is only going to reveal
this now he is appealing let me tell you
something he's appealing to the worst of
the worst of the worst
and what he's trying to do is dehumanize
dehumanize the others
and he's using it with this drag queen
stuff
this stuff is really [ __ ] weird
listen some some drag queens aren't even
gay
it's kind of funny it's a thing like I
don't know it's a performance they think
it's some something sexual literally I'm
telling you Matt Walsh believes that a
drag show is sexual because Matt Walsh
he sees it as sexual and it [ __ ] it
it's a hem problem
a drag show is someone dressed up
and dancing and singing I don't know if
you've ever been to a drag show I've
never been to one I've seen them I've
seen videos of them
it is a person
dressed up
singing and dancing just like they do on
Broadway just like they do at concerts
and it's a performance
but Matt Walsh gets a funny feeling in
his britches apparently and he gets
confused when he sees a drag queen
that's why he thinks it's sexual
because he's confused it's a him thing
and these masculine men out there
who have a problem with this
they're confused too
it's all projection
and they're using it
to demonize the lgbtq community
as if a performance of someone dancing
and singing a song
is indicative of someone's identity
it may be but what is it your [ __ ]
business
it's a performance that they're
performing
again generally singing and dancing
and dressed up doing it it's a show
they're trying to entertain
but Matt Walsh thinks it's sexual
because
he's a deviant
everything he projects
towards the others because that's what
he's doing here
that's what he's doing in it is a fine
line with these fascists
jumping from one community of
marginalized people
to the next to the next to the next
that's where they're going with this
and it's dangerous [ __ ] [ __ ] it is
dangerous [ __ ]
I listened to talk radio for years and
years and years I listened to Rush
Limbaugh Sean Hannity I'd vehemently
disagree with those [ __ ] piles of
[ __ ]
but I would listen to see what their
arguments were
because I would know what someone was
gonna puke up on me
two or three days in advance
sometimes hours but most the time two or
three days in advance
I would know exactly what their
arguments were going to be because I
knew where they came from
it's no longer coming from that there
used to be a there's well there's still
an organization American Family
Association AFA I think is what it's
called it's supposedly a Christian
organization
and for years for years
they acted like people who had different
sexuality than them were monsters
so they would go so far as to have
pastors come do some of their events and
talk about executing
these people people humans for being who
they are
listen you may not like homosexuality
you may not like someone else's
love for dressing up and singing and
dancing
for art you may not agree with someone
else's religion
but that does not give you the freedom
to oppress their rights that's not
Liberty [ __ ]
just like Matt Walsh has the absolute
Liberty to be a vile piece of [ __ ]
trash because he does Matt Walsh has the
Liberty to say what I'm about to show
you
I believe that Matt Walsh has the
Liberty to be a dumb [ __ ] and to
be a bigot
you have that Liberty now you cannot
incite it
and you cannot you cannot be to where
you're acting on it now it's a hate
crime
there are crimes around hate Matt
but let me tell you something
listen
to what they're telling you when they
tell you who they are
it is vitally important and you can do
something about this and I'm not talking
about trying to cancel Matt Walsh Matt
Matt Walsh will be go into the trash bin
of History
and he'll be known as a vile piece of
[ __ ] garbage
at this time in our history 30 years
from now people will be people will be
speaking of of people who follow Trump
and did this did this bigotry against
the marginalized community of
transgender people
they will be known as [ __ ] vile trash
the same way as we we view the Nazis our
have Jesus Christ or some people in our
country now that oh yeah Nazis all that
it ain't so bad I ain't so bad I mean
what's so bad about being a Nazi
but Society will Society will place
these people these vile pieces of trash
in the garbage bin of History
but if we don't pay attention now if we
don't pay attention to what their plans
are and we let these [ __ ]
regain power they're telling you what
they're going to do and they're telling
you what the Nazis did in 1930s and
1940s
they're dehumanizing
people and humans Americans
they're dehumanizing them stripping them
of every single inch of humanity that
they have
the same way that Kanye West is going on
his Jewish media tour and absolutely
dehumanizing Jews in this country there
are Jews that own media there are Jews
that are in Media there are Jews who are
not
and he's dehumanizing all Jews by doing
what he's doing
he may not know it
but he's doing it
that's why I believe in Liberty and
freedom
I believe that Matt Walsh has the right
and the Liberty to be a dumb
[ __ ]
he has the right to think bigoted
thoughts he can't act him out that's
crime
you are no longer free to do that to act
out
your racism to act out your hate those
are crimes now they would like to change
that just like they would like to get
rid of Medicare and social security for
older folks they would like to change
that there's a lot of things they want
to change about our country because it
doesn't fit day or needs
and their wants and desires
to get rid of people Gabe Sanchez have
you watched this clip
Matt Walsh this recent clip that I'm
about to show uh I don't believe so yeah
my God it is um
it is vile and I I really I question
whether I should tweet it today and then
talk about it but really honestly I
think this is sunlight is the best
disinfectant um it's a 101 master class
in it right because of how he actually
dehumanizes people here in this clip
he's talking about drag queens and drag
shows right and um apparently matches
the dumbest the dumbest dumbest thing
I've ever heard of okay for the audience
not to know you're a performer right
we're actually on the set of filming a
deep State propaganda video
Soros Medical Group right yeah well yeah
I may or may not be about chlamydia I
don't don't I don't know who knows who
knows who knows who could know possibly
these are deep state things but hey look
a paycheck's a paycheck and it's a nice
page you know what's funny is uh all
your trolls are like oh you're not an
actor and comedian and like literally
you've been gone for two days
I was I literally flew out of I I left
LA right to go to a set to film
yesterday and then I got it up you're
not a real actor yeah yeah and then I
got a real boy I'm not I'm not a real
boy and then I got and then I got on a
plane last night and then flew back home
and here I am back here but yeah right
it was uh how was your deep State
experience at this propaganda filming it
was it was amazing they fed me free of
charge
socialism I know oh my God
how dare they they are they probably
they probably even gave you money too
which is even more socialism I'm not
sure how it is capitalism is a [ __ ]
not only that they did my makeup they
made me look whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa wait a second you're
telling me that you were in a
performance and you put on makeup
oh my God I bet they even put they
probably even picked out the clothes for
you to wear they didn't oh my God this
is egregious this is egregious I didn't
even know they put the clothes on me we
should stop this immediately this sounds
like the devil and Satan's work here you
know what's funny about this this clip
most of all because that's what I'm
getting at here
this guy
simps for a dude
who does who who takes probably three
hours to do his hair he puts on [ __ ]
makeup he puts on an oversized suit and
a girdle to make himself look thinner
than he actually is he wears heels
and slides in his shoes so he appears to
be taller and he dances around on stage
and does a little act for them so that
they get all [ __ ] you know wet and I
don't know what what it is that they
like about him but right something makes
them you know I think they have this
sexual thing with Trump but this guy is
going to demean people for doing the
exact same thing when they're dancing
and singing music because I don't know
if Matt Walsh knows this and I've never
I've never actually been to a live drag
show I've seen videos of them they're
hilarious they're great performances
yeah and really honestly I work I've
worked with some some pretty big uh
names in the in the Bay Area I did a
short film and it was really yeah
wonderful you know what you know what's
funny about this is they there are
people that believe and that have never
been to drag show have never had and
most of them look like me
um are from where I'm from which is Rule
here here's here's a fun fact I I used
to work with someone
who got into drag and he was not gay no
he was gay oh he was he happened you
know what's funny but is a lot of people
think all drag queens like automatically
oh all of them are gay like what are you
what what makes you think just because a
dude does his hair puts makeup on puts
heels on and then puts uh puts a suit of
clothes on that makes their body look
different what makes you think they're
gay because it really if that's what
makes you gay Gabe if that's what makes
you if that's their standard wouldn't
you say there's a there's Donald Trump
is the biggest homosexual that they've
ever run into you know logic that would
also make the assumption that everyone
in Hollywood is also okay if we're
putting on it
facial hair and clothes and this and
that like look like I said I I used to
work with someone who who got into drag
and he was great it was amazing he's
also a great co-worker smart [ __ ]
intelligent dude
good performer good performer oh great
performer because I'm sure I'm sure some
some drag is is bad like some acting's
bad right yeah I mean like because
there's some people who sing who have a
band right they're not that great I mean
they're okay they're not that great but
there's some that are outstanding yeah
that's the other thing I don't get is
literally drag is it's a performance and
they're singing here's a fun fact for
people I literally wear
I'm for for the characters that I play
are you gonna go with the the boobs and
brawl and your neighbors questioning you
because that well uh well here's here's
the thing I when I film my sketches
right in front of my green screen uh and
I play the female characters yeah I've
got like a blouse on and I've got a
Brawn and I've got little padding in
there and it's I wear a wig and you know
obviously you can tell because I've got
facial hair and stuff but
it's I I do that often enough right and
I don't have a problem with that and I
walk around my living room no [ __ ]
deal I don't give a [ __ ] I walk around
my living room and it's also at night so
they're like I big light that's in the
living room I want Gabe Sanchez to
um get into drag and do a drag show
dance and sing to songs
the Meghan McCain one is the one oh the
mega yeah I would do it if I was a
better singer I'm like okay but like not
great enough to like you're not that
great of a singer I'm just not that
great it's like it's just not something
I focus on I'm sure if I want to go get
lessons and stuff and did that for a
while then yeah sure I could totally so
you're saying wait wait what you're
saying is and I want to make sure I'm
clear on this
that even some of the best drag shows
those drag shows took a while to get
that good because it is a performance is
that what you're saying yeah you might
you might be able to sing but here's the
other thing the people that I know that
that have done drag or do drag like my
my um my co-worker like it was all about
like figuring out what the name was like
what his like look was gonna be you know
it was it's a whole thing right you're
putting effort into it into actually
um making it a performance and actually
somebody brought up uh
are they in the chat what are they
saying here right no no no no if anyone
if anyone has seen this movie
uh it's from the 90s it's with Wesley
Snipes and uh John linkuazamu and John
Leguizamo and also uh which John
linguizamo is one of the best performers
ever oh yeah I don't I don't know if
because he does like the stand up but
it's not really stand up it's more
theater than it is stand up right and
it's really more educational than
anything and also uh Patrick Swayze it's
from 1995 Patrick Swayze come on now I
mean yeah I don't understand how they
think Wesley Snipes Patrick's lazy and
John linguizamo are somehow deviants
because they were to do a performance I
I recommend this movie it is amazing
is that what it's called two uh to Wong
Fu thanks for everything
um Julie Newmar okay it's a movie with
those three it's got RuPaul and Jamie
Jamie's saying uh that movie is awesome
so they they agree with you exactly I
love it I mean I recently I saw it as a
kid growing up
he says recently at the Hollywood
Cemetery what year was it made do you
know what year 95 okay yeah 1995 isn't
on Netflix right now or something or
Hulu it's probably out there somewhere
you can find it on Amazon
Prime but I I personally as the other
people in the chat right now I recommend
it it's great because it was a movie
that you know he's got these three men
who obviously that you wouldn't
typically see in in real life right as
actors as as the people they do this
film it's it's so good because also
there's a lot of good values in there
about like being a woman and being
independent and standing up for yourself
basically they go to the small town you
can't you can't talk about what a woman
is because Matt Walsh does not know that
he does not know he has he actually did
a whole I don't know if you know this he
wrote a book with that question he ran
around the country trying to ask people
because he had no clue what it was so he
was going around the country asking a
lot of people so you can't this whole
idea of that uh um you know making sure
that people like Matt Walsh would know
what a woman is or being it's really
confusing to him so easy on the whole
sorry I'm sorry I will lay it off I'll
I'll stop right now don't don't get him
confused but because you know what I
think you know what I believe this is
because I've been around a lot of these
[ __ ] trumped up white dudes in my
life
what this drag show thing is what the
reason why they think it's sexual is
because they get confused right they
they find the show sexy right so they
call into and they know that this is a
address someone in Drag and they
definitely gave their death only
not
homosexual gay they are definitely not
then that and that and Confused them to
confuse them like that gave is egregious
I think they definitely there's a bit of
that short circuiting that happens
within that like Maga brain right where
they see those things that they were
never able to try do experience and
they're part of a culture that says that
is uh some crazy taboo un uh uh uh just
just something that just isn't allowed
right right
and there's a lot of confusion like you
said they're like oh I want to try that
I know that's like maybe I have these
feelings maybe this is great but I can't
say it's great because other people that
I'm like a part of will be like you're
gay right well I mean I mean to be
honest I would I would almost imagine
that if you went through Matt Walsh's
private cell phone or his private
computer yeah history yeah I can't
imagine that his um I almost bet he's
watched transgender porn and the dude
that some of these gangs are probably
absolutely [ __ ] addicted to it which
there's nothing wrong with it I mean
that's what you want to watch fine but
that's the reason why is there they're
getting confused I mean they they
they're not secure in their sexuality
they're not securing their own skin and
that's why they want to burn down other
people being comfortable in their own
skin because whether you're gay or
straight or whatever for you to put on a
costume like that and drag and to
perform like that you have to be
comfortable with this yeah 100 there's
no way that you have any that you that
you're that you are not comfortable do
doing that you have to be extremely
comfortable to put on a performance like
that 100 it's not only the thing of like
going on stage as yourself like that
already causes anxiety for people but
then in order to put yourself out there
in a very vulnerable position right that
you're saying great I'm not only going
to be myself but I'm going to dress up
in something that people will make fun
of that people won't see me as that
people will think Ah that's weird which
only adds fuel to the fire so for those
people who do do drag right and they
perform those shows and they do those
things
[ __ ] Yeah man they are some of the most
confident people I know because they
have the the strength and the power to
go up there do their thing and then say
yeah I don't [ __ ] care what you say
look you could you can insult me you can
do this but guess what at least I feel
happy and comfortable doing this as
opposed to you that comes from this I
gotta attack you personally which is a
lot of what the Maga Republican core
debate becomes which is they don't have
an argument so then it's attacked you on
a personal side they make fun of your
weight they make fun of your face your
hair your your appearance whatever it
might be they come after those things
and they say well you're ugly because
whatever right and they don't have any
argument for Whatever It Is Well I mean
I mean these guys are running around
acting like that you can't wear a skirt
if you have a wiener like literally and
they have no idea that there's a whole
[ __ ] culture that wears what we would
see as a skirt in this country and they
don't even wear underwear underneath the
skirt and it's called a guilt they did
and really it is it is [ __ ] laughable
that they believe and and um if you
would pull the Rudy Giuliani drag show
clip for me you know what you're what
I'm talking about yeah yeah because
we'll show that after the Matt Walsh
thing because I think I think that that
is so important to watch after this clip
to know how [ __ ] serious they are
it's not a it's not about drag queens
this this talk that I'm about to show
you this this diatribe this rant that
Matt this that Matt Walsh goes on this
[ __ ] hatred and bigotry it has
nothing to do with drag shows it has
nothing to do with people dressing up in
skirts or dressing up as women or if
you're a man or you're whatever it is
there's nothing to do with that it has
to do with they they want to exterminate
the lgbtq community they want to get rid
of them is what they want and they'll do
it by any means necessary when they take
power he even [ __ ] says it in the
clip he tells you what they're doing and
again and it's nothing to do with drag
shows and the reason why is because a
drag show has nothing to do with
sexuality I mean maybe the song they're
singing is it has to do because it's the
song but they're not stripping right
they're not they're not taking off their
clothes and doing lap dances or having
sex the only reason why Matt Walsh
thinks it's sexual is because he's
confused it's a hem problem right not
the drag show problem right it's a hymn
problem is what it is and again I've
never actually been to a live drag show
but I've seen a lot of them on on camera
and they're [ __ ] hilarious and really
some of them are really good some of
them are absolutely exciting and
exceptional I mean they can get crazy
especially when they have lights in the
state age and they have a huge audience
it can get crazy
um because they're they're just
wonderful performances because they're
actually performing really good music
yeah singing it really well there's a
venue down the street that I think I
don't know if it's every Friday or every
other Friday but they have drag shows
there and the one thing I pulled up the
comment that Barbara has which is an
example of someone who everyone is like
oh this is the funniest person because
he is right or was Robin Williams and
Mrs Doubtfire is just one example right
one example where the whole [ __ ]
movie or at least like 80 of the movie
he's in drag he's pretending to be Mrs
Doubtfire he's in a whole costume he's
got everything they did the makeup and
it's nothing it's not has nothing to do
about sex nothing nothing to do about
nothing not a goddamn thing about sex
but that's where these people go because
they're deviants they I mean they're
absolutely obsessed
obsessed I mean you remember how
obsessed they were about Harry Styles
when he wore a dress oh my God God
forbid he wore a [ __ ] dress for a
photo shoot
he painted his nails no I I mentioned
this yesterday is that you know long ago
when
um before even photographs even pictures
they would dress little boys up in
dresses because dresses are pretty
they're cute right right so they would
put a little boy in a dress and take a
photo of them and they would look like a
girl but it wasn't it had nothing to do
with masculinity or or or the dress it
was about the little kid being cute that
was it over
I don't know if you if you have this I
believe I have photos of this as a kid
uh in Catholicism right and you're
getting baptized yeah you know you have
a baby
you've got this like kind of loose
fitting what looks like a dress
oh my God oh my God
it's Matt Walsh Catholic I don't know I
don't know but I can only imagine that
the childhood that Matt Walsh had was
oh absolutely I think that's where a lot
of this is probably I mean we've all got
issues right but like a lot of those
issues will obviously come back to like
what our upbringing was and our
childhood was and I can almost say
299.99 like like it's like one of those
hand sanitizer 99.9 of drones are killed
certainty that Matt Walsh grew up in a
household where his father was probably
uh you know maybe he was abusive but he
was definitely not okay with that
lifestyle and probably his mother wasn't
very supportive and you know it was
probably not a very happy and healthy
relationship because the type of person
that comes strong at you has either been
indoctrinated through religion or has
been indoctrinated through their
household their their upbringing as a
child to believe that something is bad
it's taboo you shouldn't do it just
because it makes you feel different
doesn't make it bad doesn't make it uh
evil doesn't make it something that you
actually can't do but it's the sexual
confusion that he gets twisted yeah and
and it's his own it's his own it's a
Matt Walsh problem this is from the 19th
so this is from a couple days ago on his
show
um this thing's two minutes long I might
not play all of it
um but let's let's listen to a bit of it
of what his what his plans are when they
regain power so I was not previously
familiar with the term drag mom
though from Context it seems that this
is just another way of describing a
professional groomer
okay so what he's describing is someone
who's uh who does drag is a parent he
cannot he can't get it through his thick
skull because he's like wait a second
you mean a man who dresses it as a woman
can have a baby well well I mean they
can have children dummy he doesn't
understand he's not quite understanding
that like I don't know if uh if a parent
was a police officer they might be cop
mom or cop dad or police mom or police
dad same way as like firefighter or yeah
yeah you know what whatever the
profession I mean what is what does he
considered the people that dress up
their their daughters for pageant shows
and things like that right like if we're
gonna really talk wait a second game
that is that's a little girl dressing up
as a little girl see and that and he
loves that because that seems very
sexual to Matt Walsh and he is kind of
picking to Jesus because he likes the
the underage marriage thing he
definitely likes that I mean he said
under you know 16 under was like we had
a peak 1957
one of those things where I'm like look
dressing up little children to perform
in a hyper-sexualized way seems like if
we're going to talk about drag then we
we better bring that same energy to that
[ __ ] topic right because that in and
of itself is like do I want to put a kid
through that do I not only not only in
the dress enough fashion but do I want
to force a kid to go through that type
of competition where you're literally
judged on your looks
in a in a society where we already judge
people based on their looks especially
women to be like you're not thin enough
you're not blonde enough you're not you
know uh
pale enough whatever it might be right
like those are the things
that Society already [ __ ] puts on
women there's already that stress so
when it comes to
dressing little girls up into uh you
know a pageant show stuff and putting
that unwanted pressure and stress on
them like we better bring the same
energy over to that because I feel like
that's something that has more
detrimental emotional mental impacts on
someone especially if they don't want to
do it right they don't know what they're
getting into they're a child so their
parents are like oh we're going to dress
you up and they probably think at the
first like this is great because I'm
playing I'm doing dress-up
and then it becomes a real thing where
they're like oh now I get to learn these
skills and you got to compete and you
got to perform and do all this stuff it
just seems like if we're gonna if we're
gonna bring that energy into into drag
moms then let's also talk about you know
pageants and the in the type of kind of
trauma or or or experience or or you
know whatever that might bring on a
small child who can't bring that right
the same age that someone's like oh they
can have a kid you know they they they
can have they can't make the choice for
themselves to get abortion but they're
old enough to have a kid [ __ ] you well I
mean that's that's what these people
want apparently
like Matt Walsh listen listen and I've
been saying this for months that they
want to take consent away from parents
for their children that's really what
they're wanting here Matt Walsh wants to
take consent away from the parents for
children because listen what he says
here the uh quote drag child is handed
over to the drag mom to be groomed and
conditioned it seems to be essentially a
sort of pedophilic predatory farm system
that the groomers have set up
so
what can be done about this that's
really the question
we've established that this is happening
and it's only getting worse over time
progressivism does what the name
suggests what the label suggests it's
progressivism so it progresses except
that it progresses in the same sense
that say cancer progresses okay so here
he goes he's going to call he's going to
call the lgbtq community he's going to
refer to them as cancer now again
he's starting to tread in an area where
it starts to sound really fascist really
quick
um and he's demonizing an entire
Community uh for for again people who
are performers these are performers
most drag queens don't they're not
running out I'm like you're not going to
the grocery store
in in their in their drag get up it's
it's it is a performance yeah
um that's what it is let's continue
to keep spreading and getting worse and
eating away at our civilization until it
is stopped
or until it destroys its host
and just like cancer stopping it
is not a gentle or a painless process
okay so here he's describing here he's
describing now I I'll admit I have said
that that trumpism is a disease in this
country right and I believe that we
should give an off ramp for this disease
but I'm not suggesting that we eradicate
the disease
um and watch what he says even further
he gets more dark it's getting really
dark here Gabe but listen to how dark it
gets
farther along the cancer is the more
aggressive you have to be in fighting it
culturally we are approaching if we
haven't already reached a terminal state
which means we have to be all the more
aggressive which calls for two things
first
obviously
involving children in drag events in any
capacity
should be outright criminalized
everywhere there is no other way you
know this doesn't stop until police are
breaking down the doors of these places
and carting the adults away in handcuffs
okay so there there you see it it's
about it's it's about taking consent
away from you
and there's a reason why they want to
take [ __ ] consent away from you
because they want to control your
children folks right that's what they
want this is all about them controlling
the youth that's why Matt Walsh is
obsessed with children's genitalia he's
obsessed with when when a when a young
girl can get married he's not he's not
he's not stressed out when a when a man
can man can get married
no uh young men aren't going to get
married it's going to be older men
marrying younger women I mean he
literally is assessed they want to take
your consent away is what they want
charge them all as pedophiles throw them
in prison and and whenever they get out
if they do get out put them on the sex
offender registry for life
if they get out
this guy is [ __ ] sick man the guy who
said we should marry underage girls
wants to put other people on the
registry well bro we better start with
you because you're on the air talking
about how oh
Peak peak time to have kids peak time in
terms of when a woman or a a female was
developed to have a child you know we
hit that [ __ ] in 1957 and we should
bring it back young girls make fertile
babies right like that's what they want
it's like then those young babies then
turn into young moms and they make even
more fertile babies
this guy's [ __ ] gross and the type of
the the type of projection that he
brings to this conversation to be like I
don't understand what this is all about
so it's evil to me it's bad it's taboo
we can't do it no one should and so we
should force people to do
what we can't do right we don't we don't
want to do those things so we need to
control them it's like the other day
when he was
I'm trying to remember specifically what
the the topic was but there was a video
where he was like I don't really
understand it it's satanic it sounds
satanic to me that way and I can see if
I can pull up the clip but yeah well I
think it was anime oh yeah right it was
anime he was like an anime I don't
really I don't really know it I don't
really get it but it seems satanic to me
he's what dude dude's got a problem but
listen listen he goes further he goes
further because I want people to hear
this part listen to this
that man in the first clip dancing
around with his skirt up
should be treated legally as a child
predator
that that's the level of protection that
our children are owed and the people
sexualize and exploiting them are owed
that level of punishment
this is something that needs to start in
red States and if Republicans take over
the White House it should be handled on
the federal level as well so I was
handled on the federal level so you know
it's a federal police to go around
rounding up people because they dress up
now let me show you something here
um about who they need to round up first
I wanna I want to um I want to make sure
this is very clear
and make sure Matt Walsh
um does his duty and um decides to round
up these two gentlemen here
who are obviously sexualizing things
because and really honestly they do
sexualize in this video
um they actually do sexualize it but you
see the words on the show the mayor's
inner circle press Rose 2000 the year
2000.
22 years ago let's see who's in this
video
who is that
whoa wait a second
oh whoa that looks like who is that he's
a lot thinner not as yeah you know
not as many not as many cheeseburgers
right well it was 22 years ago this is a
lot of buckets of chickens ago yeah it's
true let's let's see who the who the
lady is
you know you're really beautiful
and a woman that looks like that has to
have her own special scent oh thank you
maybe
maybe you could tell me what you're
thinking this thing
does that does that woman look familiar
is that
America's mayor I think that's Rudy
Giuliani whoa that is exactly who it is
Gabe this is Rudy Giuliani dressed up as
a woman in a bit in a gag they're
performing here right now you know
whatever the [ __ ] you want to think
about this this is totally this is
actually ridiculous it's a piss-poor
performance here
um again I've watched a lot of drag
videos and this one in particular is the
worst one I've ever seen well I mean
what do you expect right it's something
they want to try and they want to do so
when they because here's the other thing
they go oh it was easy anyone can do
that anyone can do that and it's like
yeah sure anyone could do that that
doesn't mean that you're [ __ ] good at
it right right exactly well I mean
Giuliani definitely can dress up and
drag it's not that difficult to dress up
I mean you could put lipstick on a pig
any day of the week but that doesn't
mean that your Pig's gonna get the blue
ribbon well let's continue to watch and
see where this goes because this seems
criminal to me at this point by Matt
Walter Sanders I think we should get
both of these two and round them up and
lock them up for sexualizing children
for some ungod known reason that because
he's dressed as
um in lipstick and a wig in women's
clothing but we should definitely round
them up let's watch
what the [ __ ]
I like that this may be the best of all
wait wait wait
whoa Turkey Boy you oh
Donald I thought you were a gentleman
you can't say I didn't try
which is uh pretty much in line
wait there you go
there's the evidence that you need Matt
Walsh
um so if you're gonna come come after uh
parents
and you're gonna come after
um the consent for parents because a
dude dresses up in a dress
you really you really should
um come hard after Donald Trump and Rudy
Giuliani for this video not only that
but I mean it was clear you know that
Rudy as that character didn't want what
he did but he did it anyway
and he forced himself on her on him
and uh it's
it's like even in a bit he's going to be
his true self he's going to take
advantage without consent
I mean it truly is who he is yeah so
let's see I'm trying to download the um
okay sorry sorry we're gonna go to Bone
end of the week we gotta get the bone in
the week and I I want to uh
I want to say that well we're gonna have
about 30 minutes here right yeah that's
fine you bone it so maybe we'll we've
been going over on bonehead anyways yeah
it seems like so um we're gonna get the
bone in the week very soon here I
promise I promise I promise we'll get to
the Bone end of the week
um but one last thing on this this Matt
Walsh thing yeah this is why it is so
important right now that you are
participating in this election
because as he said at the end
and again this is all projection when
they talk about how the the FBI and law
enforcement is coming after and it's
being used politically and that's a
political arm of the democratic party
that they're projecting right
they're projecting and he's telling you
that they're projecting he's saying hey
hey you know what we're gonna do
you know what we're gonna do we're gonna
come after you we're gonna jail you and
round you up right is what he's saying
when we take over the federal government
he can't wait he will love love to be
the head of whatever Department then
goes kicking in people's doors in bars
or clubs or whatever the plate the venue
might be where somebody is having a drag
show
and then just arrest anyone that he's
like oh you look different if you're
coming with me right and it's and then
it's soon it's soon soon after that
becomes something it's not just drag
we're pulling you out because you said
this you look this you wore this color
right these are all these things where
he said that the other day too about
Pink as if pink is a pink automatically
makes you a girl like ah come on man I
mean it's weird I mean like Kanye West
or the artist formerly known as Kanye
West yay uh he wore pink poles all the
time he made a whole thing about it when
he first started he's like you wouldn't
expect a rapper like me
wearing a pink Polo speaking of Kanye
West
isn't he on our bone end of the week
Paul oh he is most definitely on our
pole he just keeps
keeps on the gift that keeps on giving
Adidas is having a tough time let's do
this let's go to a break and when we
come back we will bring you bonehead of
the week stick around don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[Music]
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
your favorite time of week
s
Friday
second hour as every Friday
[Music]
we shall bring you bonehead of the week
where you vote you decide who is the
bonehead of the week and me and my great
co-host actor working actor or deep
State propagandist video maker for the
Soros Medical Group either way is here
joining us Gabe Sanchez the audience is
so excited that you're here on Friday
because you know what happens every
Friday
every single head of the week bonehead
of the week
so let's get to it
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to bonehead of the week
Gabe it says you're back you've been
gone for a couple of days back for
bonehead of the week as we are every
single Friday here on the Tony Michaels
podcast and replaying on the Midas touch
Network every single Friday so don't
forget to subscribe to our YouTube
channel the Tony Michaels podcast click
subscribe and the bell notification so
you don't miss a thing also if you're on
the mind is touch Network watching the
replay right now make sure to hit that
subscribe button it is not that
difficult just hit subscribe on our
Channel and the mind of studs Channel
also if you want to vote because that's
the thing about the bonehead of the
weekend
is you vote the audience votes you
decide we break it down for you because
there's no stopping the vote there's no
stop the steal there's no rig in the
count here on the Tony Michaels podcast
and here's how you vote Gabe you go over
to Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you
follow us there you can vote there you
can also vote on our YouTube channel on
the community tab you know what a
communion tab is you just go to the
channel while you're subscribing Gabe
and over on the side it says Community
just hit the community tab boom there's
the polls and we throw some memes and
stuff in there too
you know every once in a while we'll put
some new merch out so we'll announce it
there on the community tab speaking of
numerous holy moly everyone's been
loving these I think it's getting cold
outside and people are preparing to
stand in line to vote no matter how long
they have to stay in line no matter how
cold it is because they've been running
over to
store.thetonymichaels.com to grab their
zip up hoodies hoodies sweaters and they
all say the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not Liberty
it's our motto here at the Tony Michaels
podcast so go grab your hoodie or your
zip up hoodie it's getting cold and
you're gonna have to stand in line these
Republicans are definitely going to do
everything they can to make sure
but you have a difficult time voting but
you must vote you must you have to crawl
over broken glass and hot coals to make
sure your voice is heard so don't forget
to go to
store.thetonymichaels.com and grab your
warm Liberty gear there
gave our boneheads this week woo boy
can't get out of the news Kanye West is
one of them uh Randy Kaufman never heard
of this guy until just now a couple days
ago yeah but it's not surprising he is a
manga Republican so we'll explain that
and then Senator Lindsey Graham
Senator Lindsey Graham
where should we start I think we should
start with this Randy Kaufman figure do
you know who this Randy Kaufman guy is
I didn't know about who he was I was I I
don't I think it was when I was
traveling to go to to go film on set and
I saw people saying Maga masturbator and
I was like oh God oh God what is going
on right now like who is this someone
that we know or is this someone that is
like soon to be Infamous for here is
Randy Kaufman
um
I don't know if you have to say much
Beyond this but here's what happened
Gabe so apparently
he's running for some kind of college
board or college something right
he is he is an outright Maga
um Republican
and he's running for a board that
oversees education at a certain campus
now he was caught by a police officer at
this campus in his truck
with his pants down apparently
waxing the old carrot playing with his
PUD choking the chicken as it were if
you know what I'm saying playing with a
little baby carrot yeah that's what he
was doing apparently wow um we have it
on a local report on news three here
let's give it a listen for just a second
our Brianna Whitney is here now with the
details of this arrest and the
implications Brianna for the election
yeah Derek there's a lot of factors to
all of this for one thing early ballots
have already gone out with Randy
Kaufman's name on them but until he
formally withdraws with the county
recorder's office he could still win
even with a public sexual indecency
charge
so he was charged with sexual indecency
again it appears that he was parked in
his truck and he was near a preschool
that is on campus
um at the same campus where he's trying
to be elected to the board it doesn't
seem like this is going to go well for
him with the ballot
you know the only question I have is how
many people actually mark his name on
the ballot like that's gonna be the real
tell here like that's what I want to
know yeah is how many people I mean you
know they're willing to vote for these
these crazy Maga Kooks
um but you know
well you know it takes one to know one
so I'm sure there's a lot of people that
totally support him from the Republican
party we also know that Republican party
is full of projection and denial you
know I didn't do it I didn't do it it's
like dude we literally call you in your
truck
no I'm not I'm not against watching porn
or again choking your chicken however
you want to say it but you probably
should do it in the privacy of your home
right look if you're gonna if you're
gonna do it you know it's like do it in
the bathroom or somewhere you know like
somewhere in your own home you know your
body your choice don't put that [ __ ]
under other people yeah especially near
a preschool now apparently the the
police officer on the scene actually uh
kind of gave the what for to Kaufman
Kaufman asked if he was going to put the
fact that they were at a preschool in
the report and the officer apparently
told him look um
it's kind of weird that the kids are out
playing and you're sitting here doing
what you're doing yeah I'm gonna put it
we're gonna put it in there right you
[ __ ] creep right so this this uh
gentleman here on the TV is a political
analyst
um and he's he's speaking about the
election but listen to the Dismount here
I think that this causes people to go to
maybe hold their ballots longer because
they'll say well what about these other
candidates what if something else should
pop up
what if something else should pop up
Gabe I think that's all we need to say
about the Republican party yeah I think
like every day there's always something
probably like oh look this person who's
an aide also found out that they were
having loads of of child porn you're
like
I don't know what is popping up over
there but speaking of popping up Lindsey
Graham
he's popped up in the news all of a
sudden again Gabe is he gonna have to
have to do some testifying under oath
what do you think uh I think he will I
think
um you know I I think you talked about
it earlier you know his his history as a
uh you know Jag not a jag off but a Jag
well uh easy
may he may identify as a Jag Goff I
don't know yeah I know he's he's
certainly uh someone that will end up
having to uh he'll have to talk he'll
have to say something he'll have to come
forward and actually give testimony he
can't he can't avoid this any longer
right so well and and he he
claiming that he might go to the Supreme
Court I don't know if he will
um I don't think Lindsey Graham would
want a loss in the Supreme Court for
this
um and I think the reason why Lindsey
Graham definitely does not want to go
testify and be questioned by Fulton
County Prosecutors because because he is
actually being questioned and wants to
be questioned I actually don't believe
Lindsey Graham is a target here everyone
thinks Lindsay's going to go to prison
maybe committed crimes I think he knows
what crimes are committed that's why
they want to question him and Lindsey
Graham doesn't want to incriminate
himself but she knows he can
inadvertently criminate himself even
though he thinks he knows all the facts
he may not know and he knows this as a
prosecutor he was a Jag prosecutor and
so this idea that you know everything
that prosecutors know is really it's not
a thing that you should just assume and
what you should do your best bet is to
lawyer up and do not incriminate
yourself that's what Lindsey Graham is
doing Lynch Graham knows he's not a
Target because he's being questioned
he's likely not a Target
um there is another Target that they're
trying to aim for Trump trump
um and the fake collector scheme
um but Lindsey Graham knows that there
is potential that he could have criminal
liability if he goes in and talks to
them so he's trying to avoid it at all
costs
um but Kyle has it here he says just in
the appeals court panel unanimous me
unanimously ruled Lindsey Graham cannot
be questioned by Fulton County
Prosecutors about his post-selection
conversation with Georgia officials they
are rejecting his claim of total
immunity under speech and debate clause
because what what Lindsey Graham the
closet he's trying to use is basically
saying hey I'm a sinning senator in the
government right I am just questioning
and making sure that everything was done
fairly inside the government which is a
really stupid argument that he can't go
be questioned by prosecutors he has that
right to make that claim but he doesn't
have the the right and this is what the
appeals panel is saying he doesn't have
the right to immunity because he has the
ability to question this on a official
level because Lindsey Graham being a
United States Senator has an official
capacity to question uh an election he
he has that Authority yeah anyone can
anyone can question it's just what your
role was
after question exactly and what the
intent and motive was right if you were
like hey you should throw out these
ballots these these legal mail-in
ballots it begins to be a little illegal
well just like yesterday when I was
talking about these uh these Dropbox
Watchers have you seen this this clean Q
Anon vote USA or something like that I
don't remember what the name is
something like that they're they're
taking pictures of people dropping uh
mailing ballots in ballot boxes secure
ballot boxes uh yesterday we watched a
video on Maricopa County yeah and I said
you are free to take video and pictures
on a public sidewalk that is a thing you
are free to do but you you aren't free
to do it if you have criminal uh motives
and intent like it can be a crime if
your motives are Criminal Just because
it is legal to do doesn't mean you're
legally doing it just like Lindsey
Graham knows that just because he has
the legal authority to do this doesn't
mean he was legally doing it and there's
criminal exposure so that's why Lindsey
Graham popped up on bonehead of the week
now we have a dishonorable mention here
uh Liz truss who the hell is Liz trust I
don't know who this is who is this
are we supposed to know who this is well
she's certainly not in this country oh
you might find her in the UK uh as uh
the incompetent
um woman that conservatives love to
compare to
um
I don't know uh Kevin McCarthy's uh what
what specific bill was it or plan I'm
trying to oh yeah I don't know economics
the Republican we want to strip your
Economy Way right right well here here I
got a great video from Larry Kudlow if
for people who don't know this TV
personality dumbass was actually because
he was on TV was in the Trump
Administration that's yeah I I think
that's the only reason why anyone was in
the [ __ ] Trump administration because
they were in front of a camera but
here's this is September 23rd okay so
this is not that long ago I you know why
it's not that long ago you know why it's
not that long I think this Liz trust she
became prime minister at this point and
it's almost like that's the news is she
had to step away because of her economic
plan but let's see what Larry kudlow's
take was on September 23rd the U.S
midterm elections Cavalry arrived early
in London what do I mean by that well
the new British prime minister Liz truss
has laid out a terrific supply side
economic growth plan oh Gabe you hear
that great holy moly this is almost
gonna be like it is an absolute fairy
tale fantasy play out a blueprint for
what Republicans are gonna do in this
country this was September 23rd of this
year surely this does not turn out awful
in the end this story can't have a bad
ending right no maybe I I don't know
let's play the clip
which looks a lot like the basic thrust
of Kevin McCarthy's commitment to
America
ouch let's start with trust she is
slashing tax rates and deregulating
energy I just love it that's the liberal
Business Media this is so wonderful the
liberal Business Media you know what I'm
talking about is is he talking to Kanye
thing is that what he's saying I don't
know I can't when they start when they
start using every one of these people
are like my voice is being suppressed my
rights are being suppressed I'm
oppressed I'm this I'm that it's like
dude you got your own [ __ ] show right
and you're and you're [ __ ] simping
for the new PM Liz truss and her
economic plan where you're cutting
you're cutting taxes and you're
deregulating I'm sure this doesn't go
well I'm sure this doesn't go which I
would say that because we know from our
own history that [ __ ] ain't good
what's funny is it took 44 days 44 days
for them to realize this is this not
only not only is this plan a bad idea
she's a horrible idea watch this it's
now trashing her plan that tells me
trust has it exactly right because the
fact is Gabe the reason why she's on the
bone end of the week is she now resigned
she resigned
44 days the reason why she had to resign
is because the economic plan wasn't
gonna work
I mean if we if we want to measure this
you know give it another metric
um I think this is a fair one right this
is something we've had on the show
um and his his name is now used as a as
a a way to measure things oh really he
even had he even had something to say
the other day when her resignation came
through oh I think I know what you're
talking about because people are talking
about the time period like how long how
long was it how long one thing one thing
that was trending was lettuce because it
seems like
a head of lettuce lasted longer than she
did but maybe just maybe I think I know
who you're talking about
um is Anthony scaramucci
um he tweeted oh no actually this is
different he actually oh that was today
oh okay unrelated I'm Jumping the Shark
hey hey well hey I mean we're we're
getting we're gonna get to um next we're
gonna get to Steve Bannon because I
think he got the the alpha cook
um yeah we we totally jumped the shark
here Steve Bannon gets here we go okay
now I found it sorry I was a little
early a little early yeah well you know
it happens you get distracted you gotta
memorize propaganda scripts for George
Shores medical groups
um let's see here
um
here we go Liz trust lasted four and
point one scare emojis now I actually I
quote this and I said official this is
got this comes from the mooch himself it
does totally has to be I mean we we had
him on the show and we asked asked him
can you give us the actual measure of
time right if you want to go watch that
interview just what you need to do is
you need to you need to subscribe and
follow the Tony Michaels podcast on
YouTube that that interview is still up
you can go see uh Anthony scaramucci
tell us exactly what a scaramucci is
what's this what's this next one what's
this this is also I believe what you
meant about the lettuce
um yeah all of these all of these
scaramucci ones are just coming out of
the world okay okay I see one scaramucci
equals a carton of milk one trust equals
a head of lettuce so it's like the same
so ahead yeah right it's like at what
point do they go bad did they spoil do
you have to toss them out does a carton
of milk go bad in 11 days I mean I don't
know that a carton milk is last 11 days
in my house but I don't know I mean I'm
guessing I think that's past the point
at which it's like I think he's just
trying to say if you're gonna compare
them with groceries right right right
like food products I think what it's
like past the point of like buy or sell
by or whatever this is like when it
expires or whatever oh Liz trust oh I'm
so happy that the the conservatives in
this country were so excited that Liz
trust became the Prime Minister as a
blueprint for their great plans for our
country and it didn't last 44 days well
I said 44 45 days I guess right and it's
done you gotta round up a little bit you
know right now today is sentencing
Friday mm-hmm it's sentencing day on
Friday and we know that Alpha cook this
week Steve Bannon was sentenced today
yeah a lot of people are a little
confused and a little upset about this
sentencing Gabe yeah I mean rightfully
so well I mean some people think it
should have been more the judge
obviously
um in the hearing said look it's going
to be between one and six months yeah
and I I think I said this a couple
months ago I thought well when when when
they announced that he was going to be
sentenced on this day I said I I think
you'll get three or four months that's
what I thought he would get I believe
that's what I said I'd have to go back
and look at the tape but I believe
that's when I thought I said about four
months so that's that's pretty that's
pretty close
um but here's the thing is people are
upset that Steve Bennett is not in jail
but that is not normally how prisons
federal prison sentences work in the
first place if generally if you're out
on pre-trial and we know this from the
Bob McDonald case I I mentioned this in
the first part of the podcast the Bob
McDonald case he was the governor of
Virginia he was charged with felonies he
went to court and was found guilty of
felonies
um and the judge let him stay out on
appeal meaning you have this ability to
appeal of course and because it's a
non-violent crime and you've been on on
pre-trial and you know yada yada yada
the judge can grant you the ability to
stay out of jail while you're on appeal
here's the problem that Steve Bannon has
okay that that that I think Bob McDonald
had as well but he went to the Supreme
Court and they overruled his conviction
now Steve Bannon has this problem
the appeals process is going to be done
by judges and his charge is contempt
and judges are normally the ones who
hold people in contempt so I don't know
that they're going to be
I don't know on Steve Bannon inside here
for contempt appeals judge or not really
the other thing too is Steve Bannon
didn't have a defense in the trial
that's why it didn't take very long and
it didn't take the jury very long to
find him guilty because he didn't have a
defense because he did what they said he
did right like and he even said yeah I
did that thing like he's he he made this
executive privilege claim in the end
that fell apart on him yeah
um totally fell apart on him and that's
where his defense just absolutely lost
it
now I want to reassure the audience
he will more than likely
99.9 sure as sure as I was that he would
give three or four months I am sure that
he'll lose this appeal no matter how far
he takes it
he's going to serve every single day of
this four months when you get sentenced
in a federal court like this to prison
you serve every single day now he's
going to get one day credit Gabe for the
day that the great day the great thing
yeah that perp Walk The Bop the Bureau
of Prisons will give him credit for that
one day because he was detained so they
have to give him one day's credit for
that detainment while he was being
arraigned because he was under arrest
um so they'll give him that so he's only
got one day credit but here's what I
don't understand about
Steve Banning here and about this uh
this sentencing and then we'll move on
to the to the to the winner of the week
the bonus of the week
here's what I really don't get why Steve
Bannon just didn't turn himself over at
this point to serve out this four months
he knows he's gonna have to do every
single day of this well because if he
well well I was gonna say you know
there's another figure in history and
maybe Steve Bannon could write a book
maybe he could have wrote a book over
the next four months you know what I've
even got a great title for it a great
title for a book that Steve Bannon could
have wrote over the next four months my
struggle could be I think that would be
a perfect title I cry into a book about
his struggle and and blame all kinds of
other people and you know really Stoke
fear with his book and try to gain a
movement with his book called Mind
struggle I don't know maybe he should
think about that yeah I mean he could
totally go for the victim game I I
thought you know in my mind I was like
oh maybe he'll do like a little graphic
novel and it'll be called like the
decomposing corpse you know and it's
like the reanimated she's like a third
book where you flip yeah you see him go
from melting like yeah just like up to
adult life but then at the same time he
simultaneously just like flaking away
and and leaving
his his remnants could be called the
decomposition of a scab I don't know it
could be I don't know scabby Steve is
what we call him here so
Steve scab Bannon
or sloppy Steve as he's known by his
buddies
um is the Outlook of the week for
receiving four months in federal prison
and folks I know it's going to take a
little bit trust me he will serve this
sentence but speaking of people who
serve sentences
um he's not very good with them forming
them and he's probably going to get sued
for a lot of them that he said lately is
our bone Hen of the week winner
Kanye West or ye as he wants to be known
um and do I have that right do I have
that right yeah Kanye
yeah he's the so yay the artist formerly
known as Kanye West you know very much
the same way as like Prince is this is
this is that how he wants it that's he
he's officially changed to yay formal
but but
no I I believe that's how a lot of
people are talking about right now so I
believe that's how he wants though I'm
not going to give a lot of respect in
terms of the name that you want when
you're a you know an anti-semite so
uh forgive me if I say what your name is
originally because of the way in which
you talk about Jewish people and also
those within your community so
I don't have a lot of respect for him
you know it's one of those things where
it's like yeah well you're complaining
about having your rights taken away and
this and that but look man every private
company out there
can make their own choice based on the
things that you do things on the based
on the things that you say there are
consequences for your actions right I
mean starting to see consequences with
Adidas really getting nervous here
explain the Adidas thing though explain
it he has I haven't read too much into
it lately but he has a deal right he's
got his the shoe deal right he's a shoe
deal that he has uh with Adidas and
there well there was also a clip that
came up recently where he was in front
of a bunch of uh Adidas execs and it was
a really weird and he released it right
he put it on the internet yeah and it
was I don't know if it was like a if it
was like a power move to release it I
mean it's clearly a power move to be in
this meeting with with them and they
were just sitting in this in the group
in chairs and he was like no local look
and he's like showing this sex tape or
this like porn or whatever it was and
it's just [ __ ] so it's so insane and
since then uh Balenciaga has also
dropped him I think that happened just
this morning honestly well I mean
they're all gonna drop him I mean Kanye
West is not only ruining His Image he's
he's ruining
um his his really his selling power here
right I mean because that's why Adidas
put had a contract with him anyways
because of his selling power but that's
really why Candace Owens and her husband
has tried to manipulate Kanye's because
of his selling power that's what the
right wants is his selling power they
could care less about God yeah and I
mean even if we were to quickly just
quickly look at the numbers for because
I had them up I was like writing a tweet
yesterday uh okay so parlor the the
failing right wing this is this is the
one that Candace Owens husband is the
CEO his name is farmer right right
George farmer and that's just the app
that's not like the cloud services side
you know the actual money making side
right they're gonna help him uh continue
to add those things in uh to run parlor
and I don't know what the if there's a
fee or included but they will help him
on that side so they're selling the
uh the one that has no value the one
that was scraped by the internet the one
where people were planning the
Insurrection on because they had no
moderation tools but to give everyone a
perspective
parlor claims to have 16 million
registered users okay however According
to some analytics some data analytics
that apptopia did they found that there
was only 40 000 daily active users
whoosh that is way less than getter
truth social gab uh
um Rumble so parlor is in the [ __ ]
right exactly it's probably not going to
exist much longer I think Twitter has
237 million active users that's what
they have right daily active users it's
a lot and this is 40 000 right this is
[ __ ] there's still a lot of people
but yeah I mean like to hold up a social
media platforms
because then there was also this other
little fact that happened is they sent
out parlor sent out this email very
excited I don't know if you heard about
this or anyone else heard about this uh
but they were very excited to say uh the
artist formerly known as Kanye West yay
has agreed to purchase parlor it's
exactly what we need for this to to move
forward and become the social network
that we believe it can be they sent an
email
and they did not blind carbon copy these
verified users oh man I've seen this
debug I didn't know what it was really
about so 300 plus people got doxxed with
their email by by sending it out to a
bunch of very because they carbon copy
instead of blind guys right so they just
put everyone a cc instead of a BCC and
they sent it out to all these people so
300 plus verified accounts these like
Elite users or whatever and the kicker
is that a lot of these people are like
we've never joined this app like like
because so wait a second so you're
saying they they actually never create
an account that parlor created exactly
so they they reserve the real estate for
that user and it's the same thing that
happened over at getter they reserved
the real estate and they scraped over
the post that people had on Twitter and
then put them on together which is Jason
Miller's uh social network he was the
former communications director Aid or
whatever uh for Trump he has getter and
they did the same thing they just
scraped things over from Twitter and
then put them in the app and they seated
that content to make it look like it was
active when it really wasn't so they
reserved a bunch of these usernames for
these people that were verified on
Twitter or big prominent Republican
names
parlor did the same thing they had
access to these emails sent them invites
to be like hey you know probably is the
way that it usually goes is they said
hey uh your account is reserved click
this does to create your account right
but in doing so when they made this
announcement for Kanye West yay uh
buying parlor they sent it out everyone
in CC instead of BC seeds so everyone
now and now I guess what happened is
it's become this super long email chain
that people are responding to and they
can't get off of because the original
names are on there so if you try to
remove yourself unless you block people
or whatever
you've got all these people who are uh
politicians prominent people in the
Republican party uh other Talking Heads
political advisors celebrities all of
these people's emails were now exposed
as this like hey get ready Kanye West is
coming to own parlor you know I wonder
if uh
a company who doesn't know the
difference between a carbon copy and a
blind carbon copy maybe that has
something to do with their success or
not success of gaining engaged users on
their platform I don't know if that's
like a maybe a thing
um really it's do not trust and I and I
have a I've got a tweet out there that
says find me one
well-designed and created app by
conservatives and I've yet to find I've
also asked for if anyone can find me a
conservative comedian right right I'm
still waiting on both of those answers
but this is another example where it's
do not trust Republicans with your data
right they will [ __ ] it up and this
isn't the first time this already
happened to parlor once where their [ __ ]
got scraped and then wasn't that during
what that was directly after January
yeah yeah that was after January and
then of course they got pulled from the
Apple store and they had to reapply and
they basically were like look you can't
have this app if you don't have
moderation we even had to go get Russian
servers because no one else would put
them on there sir yeah there wasn't
there because they were planning coups
on their app and then the cloud service
is like no you can't you can't put that
[ __ ] on our service there was a moment
in time when I really thought they were
going to go under and then they got left
but this is the story here with Kanye
West and parlor because parlor is using
Kanye to try to leverage him as true
social is in their demise because true
social really is in their demise they're
being under veteran guest investigation
there's whistleblowers involved it could
be it could be crimes it and it
definitely uh leads me to believe that
this merger with this SPAC is not going
to come to fruition which means that
they're actually the fine financial
support that they would have will
crumble into Abyss which means they
won't exist anymore unless they find
someone else to steal the money from but
this is what happens when you
participate in this kind of stuff here's
Kanye West I want to play this video of
him at this Adidas because it is Adidas
deal feel like apparently these these
new designs were supposed to be released
Adidas is having a lot of problems with
it because Kanye's making an
anti-semitic statements about Jewish
people and Jewish Americans and and
acting like there's some big cabal and
conspiracy with them all which is very
anti-semitic which is very gross and
vile but listen to what he says about
his statements and Adidas this is this
is wild
the thing about it being Adidas is like
I could literally say anti-semitic [ __ ]
and they can't drop me
I could say anti-semitic things and
Adidas can't drop me
now whoosh openly admitting what he's
doing saying dare I dare you I dare you
maybe that's what that video is about
maybe it was a warning of what of what
he has and this is why Kanye West really
is the biggest bonehead of this week and
and really honestly
um Kanye has a lot of mental health
problems we know that from history it's
no excuse here right but I believe Gabe
that there's going to be a much bigger
investigation into this as Discovery
happens in some of these civil lawsuits
because it looks like Kanye West was
also sued by George Floyd's family for
the the defamatory statements that they
he made towards George Floyd and um and
and his murder and I honestly believe
that these companies are not going to
put up with this this statement here is
defamatory towards Adidas and I'm almost
sure that they're going to lose a
shitload of money because this guy's
saying this stuff oh he's saying it like
he's saying it I'm almost sure that
Adidas if they haven't already they are
in a room full of lawyers right now
figuring out how to to see the [ __ ] out
of Kanye West I don't care what he calls
himself they're gonna see the [ __ ] out
of this guy and that is why he's the
bonehead of the week
um what was what I was going to say was
so yeah so obviously the the uh George
Floyd's family is suing for the the
amount of 250 million dollars but what I
think could be interesting to see is
that in that interview when he says that
George Floyd died by the by the cause of
um of fentanyl he brings up Candace
Owens right he says I saw like Candace
Owens sent me the name it's man I'm
telling you these these idiots they just
don't understand that what criminal
conspiracy is and I think they're gonna
[ __ ] around and find out and I think
Kanye already has and you know maybe
he's being used here maybe he's using
his microphone in the way that he wants
or again like I'm saying I believe that
he's just a bonehead and they are using
his amplifier in a way to to uh as an
ends to their means so Kanye West
you are the bonehead of the week let's
give him his dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Kanye West
ye yay whatever formerly known as
bonehead of the week that's what you
were known as thanks for participating
here on bonehead of the week here's how
you vote folks here is how you vote you
go follow at the Tony Michaels pod on
YouTube go follow our channel the Tony
Michaels podcast also if you're on the
Midas touch watching the replay
subscribe here but you can also follow
us on Twitter you vote there at Tony
Michaels pod that's what I meant to say
at first I haven't meant to do the
Twitter one at first I mean I got it
mixed around what the hell you gonna do
it's live
here's here's what you do Gabe if you
want to vote just go over to Twitter
follow at tonymichaelspod or go follow
our YouTube channel you can vote there
on the community tab do you know how to
get to the community Deb when you go to
the channel and you're hitting subscribe
there's a little tab there that says
Community hit that that's where you can
vote every single week every single
Friday here on the Johnny Michaels
podcast in the second hour and replaying
every Friday on the Midas touch Network
bone of the week and also download
bonehead a week on Sundays on Apple's
Spotify Google if you just want to
listen to the to our great beautiful
voices
but I would recommend watching it and
listening to it I actually have a
question for for the audience yeah
uh if we made you know a shirt maybe had
bonehead of the week maybe on like a
like on the like here on the patch or
something like that or you know like on
the on the on the the pocket would you
guys want would you guys wanna maybe we
could put it on the back oh we could put
it on the back let us know in the
comments what kind of bone Hen of the
week merch you want maybe we put the
bonehead of the century with his picture
and bonehead of the week logo on the
back for bone and I don't know you let
us know what your recommendations are
put them in the comments below we will
be watching and reading those speaking
of merch Gabe don't forget to go to
store not the Tony michaels.com to get
your Liberty hoodies and sweaters it's
getting cold outside you can't stand in
line to go vote
don't forget to go to
store.dtonymichaels.com for all your the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty merch you can also
get t-shirts but uh it's getting cold
outside so grab your sweater a hoodie or
a zip up Hoodie boy what a great
bonehead of the week
Kanye never miss points no never
disappointed and really speed Bannon
today's today's sentencing Friday so
yeah it's a full chock full of boneheads
and I'm sure next week will be too so we
will see you next week on Friday here on
the Tony Michaels podcast in the mind is
Dutch network if you're on the Tony
Michaels podcast stick around we got
some announcements if you're on the
Midas Dutch Network we'll see you next
week on Friday that's been bonehead of
the week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
of the week
Boom the favorite segment we're over a
little bit of time but before we go yeah
what do you got before we go oh you
gotta you got some links here breaking
news what's what the hell's going on
here
uh wrong one wrong one where's the
breaking news one that's the breaking
news one you had it oh no that was the
really news now oh I don't know
let me see the breaking news ones here
somewhere here it is
yeah that's the one not the other one
um I just sent you a link what do we got
here what I haven't read this yet what
is this this is
the Jan six committee saying pursuant to
a unanimous vote the select committee
issued a subpoena to former president
Donald Trump for testimonies and Records
relevant to the select committee's
investigation into the January 6 attack
of the United States capital and its
causes you know what's funny is that the
day that Steve Bannon is sentenced to a
prison term for contempt of congress
because the January select committee
subpoenaed him they issue a subpoena for
his orange Mussolini Jesus the
Republican Jesus Donald Trump this is
fantastic I mean gosh what great
breaking news there's what I'm I mean
obviously people people aren't happy
with the sentence that he was given for
for Steve Bannon and now it becomes a
question of like is is a subpoena really
just a a symbol or is it just more
symbolic than it is actually like
justice so now we come into question of
like what happens next right does yeah
but I think but but I think people are
getting a little bit out of hand when
they're saying it's not enough I I
predicted that he would get three or
four months that's what I thought the
judge would give and the reason why is
because this is a misdemeanor charge and
the problem is is that they could not
use the federal charges that Steve
Bannon had because Donald Trump pardoned
him right now if those charges would
have stuck they would have definitely
been able to use those in his sentencing
guidelines and the guidelines Would Have
Made It much higher because really the
prosecutors only recommended six months
and I'm very confident that the
prosecutors as much hell as Steve Bannon
as with the prosecutors through in this
case I'm almost positive that the
prosecutors gave as much as they
possibly could recommend
um was the was the guideline I forget
the money it was like 6 500 yeah it
wasn't a lot it wasn't a lot um and I
think they could go up to a hundred
thousand dollars so really honestly I
think if there's any disorder versus
Justice it's that that they didn't
actually find him
um for for all the [ __ ] that he I
mean when he does go to jail we do know
that he will actually be able to shower
for the first time in in years
well that's I feel sorry I feel sorry
for the people that have to go through
that booking process yes he hasn't had a
decent bar of soap in a long time for
sure
it's been a long time since him and a
bar of soap got intimate um that's for
sure but I I will say that he is going
to serve every single day of this four
months that's the beautiful part about
the federal system is anything under a
year baby you got to serve every day of
that there's no there's no beyond that
there's no getting out early there's no
parole you will serve four months now
that's why I didn't understand why Steve
Bannon just didn't say
hey I honestly I didn't understand why
Steve Bannon just didn't say hey I'm
going to turn myself over well I mean if
he did that then he wouldn't have the
ability to continue to talk on his show
well but obviously
here's the thing though I believe that
Steve Bannon is more concerned about his
image than he is about others oh yeah so
so the fact that he could become some
sort of Maga martyr would be much more
important and he could have oh I'm going
to prison and and think about it think
about this a second let's say there is a
huge Blue Wave which seems to be the
case with some of the early voting
indicators that we have in Georgia it
really seems like the people are going
to get out and vote just like they did
in 2018 and they did in 2020. I mean
these numbers are like there's it's
almost 90 percent higher turnout of
early voting than it was in 2018 midterm
which is unheard of unheard of in a
midterm especially in a state like
Georgia this this all the indicators are
is that people are willing to save
democracy but what could be a better
story than Steve Bannon Goes to Jail
there's a big huge Blue Wave and they
didn't win the house or the Senate he
could say see it's because I wasn't
there right it's because I wasn't
talking it's and he'd only have served
four months I mean four months in in
reality I mean yeah you wouldn't want to
go to jail for four months for sure but
in in the grand scheme of things he
would have a much better narrative when
he comes out when he's actually fending
off big huge criminal cases for this
select um or this
this elector scheme because I believe
he's tied into that oh yeah yeah I mean
it's all of them you know you've got
you've got uh Tom fitton right who tends
who said today I stand with uh with
Steve Bannon the same way that uh
Marjorie greens that I stand with you
know they should stand in a jail cell
with him I'm pretty sure that's what
they should but these remember these are
the people that we learned during the
the ninth day Tom fitton and and Steve
Bannon which you already knew about and
obviously you know uh Roger Stone these
are all people that were Whispering
these things into Trump's ear and he was
like yeah I totally will do that I mean
I I just wrapped up what was that on it
and I go through and I bring up even in
September 2020 when Trump was like I
won't commit to a peaceful transfer of
power right you know these ballots and
this and that like all this they're
saying it out loud
Matt Walsh say it out loud today he's
they're not hiding it yeah he's in he's
in The Press Room and saying yeah I'm
not going to agree to that it'll be a
continuation of anything and you're like
whoa whoa whoa uh there's a way in which
we we have a protocol and how we handle
these Transitions and it's peaceful uh
you have to transfer this over don't
[ __ ] fight it but of course Trump is
a big baby and all these other people
are like no fight it fight it fight it
commit nine tenths the law if you say
you won you won and they'll have to
fight you off
obviously it's just it's it is it is
insane to
to look back on those moments because in
those moments you were like oh this
guy's [ __ ] crazy what is he doing and
then you fast forward to January 6 and
then now that's what you've been doing
and then yeah and then now during the
the ninth day of the Jan six here and
you're like oh my God like we're putting
all these puzzle pieces together and
this is the final image of what they
were doing right well and and that is
the thing that I think was the most
amusing about the news that came out of
the Steve Bannon sentencing today is
because he acts all tough and on his
show and out in front of the press but
when it came down to it when the judge
asked him if there's anything he'd like
to say he his quote basically was my
lawyers have already talked for me
um and and what that tells me is he knew
that he needed to be in the favor of the
judge for him to let him on out on
appeal right um Steve Bannon knew that
and what it tells me is that because
Steve Bannon um didn't do the thing that
he could do to be a martyr here and just
uh you know say I'm gonna appeal this
but I'm gonna go ahead and serve the
sentence is that he is a scared little
[ __ ] yeah and he's never right everyone
saw him go medieval instead he was gonna
go medieval right he did not go medieval
today he's not gonna go medieval uh he
is terrified to serve a day in prison he
is terrified of it and that is what is
driving him here
um so good luck to Steve Bannon because
he's going to do four months
every every last [ __ ] day he's gonna
do it and if he [ __ ] around and he
tries to delay this and use this as a
delay tactic that judge will will get
him and put him in a Cell trust me that
is what they will do in the visual
system Gabe what a week
every single weekday Monday through
Friday we bring the heat here on the
Johnny Michaels broadcast Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch
I'm so glad that you did your propaganda
PSA this week it makes me really happy
that you're contributing to the Deep
State yeah I mean you know the audience
missed you the audience missed you I
missed everyone else I miss you I missed
you I had I had fun though the last two
days just ranting for two hours straight
yeah you know I had to take some naps
after them and I was I was exhausted
that's exhausted that I didn't have the
help from our great co-host Dave Sanchez
I'm we're glad to have you back the
audience we're glad to have you here
everyone have a safe and great weekend
until next Monday same time same place
Surf's Up [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon